perhaps no surprise that that kirst
armor pushed hard on on the local
election results and and what people
thought of the conservatives yeah Jane
and if you were Rishi soon at going into
pmqs this week it will be a session that
you will want to get over quickly
because you've lost a thousand
councilors a really poor performance uh
worse than internal projections as I
understand it from conservative Campaign
Headquarters there was case scenario was
750 losses and you know that kirstarma
is gonna try to pin you on that
humiliate you punish you and that's what
we saw and actually the Contours of
those exchanges were predictable in that
case starmall was pushing the you're
tired and worn out all of the country
think you should go and Rishi sunak was
saying people don't know your policies
I'm getting on with the job and I think
the final exchange the final exchange
between the two men sort of summed up
perfect their lines of attack which I
think we can have a listen to now
same old got from him every week Mr
Speaker all politics and no action we're
getting on with halving people's energy
bills freezing fuel Duty cutting the
shots of cold care and boosting pay well
he's well he's busy plotting coalitions
we're getting on and delivering for the
British people
and that that line about plotting
coalitions of course it mirrors the
interview that you did yesterday with
Kirsten yes so what's very interesting
about what came out of these local
elections is that while labor made very
good progress and kirst armor is quite
right to stand there feeling pleased
with himself uh the other party share in
the Limelight quite uh quite credibly
was the liberal Democrats and on the
projections that our sofologists or
election experts have done on these
local election results if you
extrapolate it out kierstorm is short of
an outright majority at a general
election now Jane when you look at the
mountain he has to climb in terms of the
Swing it's enormous he has to do better
than Tony Blair did back in 97 with that
landslide that was a post-war record
swing to labor or to any party and he
needs to do better than Tony Blairs it's
not unsurprising that he's not there yet
and might not get there in the next year
so now the question obviously is you're
on calls to become the largest party
but to actually govern therefore you
might need to do a deal
uh and what was interested in the
interview we did with kirstama yesterday
was a year ago kierstama
outright said I am not doing a deal with
the s p and I will not do any sort of
deal with the lib dams it's not a formal
Coalition Jane that we're talking about
it could be confidence and Supply that's
when a part you were a minority
government but a party votes for you to
get your legislation through so you have
an informal Arrangement he ruled out all
of it a year ago I went into an
interview with him yesterday expecting
him to do the same and he did not what
he did was he ruled out a deal with the
SMP he didn't rule a deal out with the
lib downs and I think what you saw at
Prime Minister's questions be it in that
question that answer to kirstama or also
in an answer that the Prime Minister
gave to Ed Davey the conservative party
might see this as an opportunity to whip
up some of the old attack lines from
previous elections about coalitions of
chaos and vote labor get the s p or vote
labor get get the liberal Democrats
what's interesting about all of this is
that uh Ed Davey as well on the liberal
Democrat side they're not ruling out a
deal with labor they are ruling out a
deal with the conservatives because they
got so badly burnt back in 2010 going
into a formal Coalition with the
conservatives and then sort of having
near Wipeout at the 2015 general
election so it's you know their local
results they don't necessarily correlate
directly to a general election it's a
long way to go labor might gain the
conservatives might shrink uh Labor's
lead you know anything can happen but
it's inevitable now that there will be
discussions about whether or not they'll
do coalitions and and instead of closing
that down for the time being yesterday
circus Dharma left the door open and I
wonder if it's because while he's going
for the outright majority that he will
say repeatedly he doesn't want to to box
himself in a maybe also it's a nod to
voters to perhaps vote tactically maybe
that's what he's doing as well